so now we want to find the center of
mass of a uniform rod and we have the
result for a continuous body which is an
integral over the body of DM r2 that
mass element DM divided by an integral
of DM now our goal is to figure out how
to apply this result specifically to
real physical objects and the key as
always is choosing a coordinate system
so now I'll draw the object again and
the first thing I'll do is choose an
origin I can pick my origin anywhere I
want I could pick it in the middle I
could put it in the middle I could put
it this end I could put it that and I
could put it down here but I'll choose
it over here because the object is
linear this is a very Cartesian system
I'm only doing a one dimensional object
so I choose my coordinate system plus X
that's step one now my origin now here
comes the crucial thing in this argument
DM is the infinitesimal mass element and
I want to pick that at an arbitrary
place in the object I don't want to pick
it at the origin I don't want to pick it
at the end note down here this is x
equals L so I'll arbitrarily pick an
infinitesimally element I'll shade it in
DM that represents this is what I'm
gonna make my summation over when I do
my integral I'm gonna add up all these
DMS and the point is is that the DMS are
different distances from the origin so
the vector and here's the next step is I
draw a picture of my vector RDF so now I
have these terms at least explained in
my diagram the next step is to turn is
to introduce an integration variable for
both of these quantities so step one was
the coordinate system
step2 was the identification of DM and
step three and I think this is
absolutely the crucial one is to
introduce the integration variable now
you'll see that will come in two
different places so this is the quantity
the distance from DM to the origin
that's changing you can see for each of
these little elements that changes
so what I'll write DM as a vector is X
Prime
which will be my integration variable in
the I hat direction so the integration
variables X Prime that's the first place
that I introduced the integration
variable and X Prime you can see will
vary and it varies from X prime equals
zero to X prime equals L and that will
show up in terms of the limits of my
integral now the second place that the
integration variable comes in is DM I
want to express DM in terms of X prime
which is a measure of where this object
is and that's how if we choose this
length here to be DX prime notice in
terms of the integration variable then I
have a relationship between DM and DX
prime DM is mass in this little element
DX prime is the length of the element
and if the whole object is a uniform rod
with a mass Capital m and a length L
then it's just given by M over L DX
prime and this quantity M over L is an
example of a mass linear mass density
which we have a skill challenge about so
I have two places where my integration
variable has been introduced and now I
can write up every piece in this
integral so let's now indicate that
we're integrating from X prime equals
zero to X prime equals L
diem is M over L DX Prime and our vector
is X Prime I hat and downstairs it's
just
M / L DX prime from X prime equals zero
to x prime y equals L and that's how I
set up the integral for the center of
mass
both of these integrals are now not
difficult to do notice it's X prime DX
prime so this integral is x squared over
2 and I get 1/2 M over L l squared and
downstairs DX prime from 0 to L is just
L so the downstairs integral is just M
over L and when you have M over L s
cancel
we just are left with a this is I'm
sorry this is just M not M over L
dimensionally incorrect so we get for
the position of the center of mass the
MS cancel one of the LS cancel and we
have an I hat in this expression so our
answer is R equals L over 2 I hat which
is exactly what we expected we expected
the center of mass to be halfway down
the rod